[Music]
and sorry not sorry news submitted by
the one and only me a taco truck
apologize for serving ice workers but
are now apologizing for the apology
oh I'm sorry I like betel I'm sorry
again
what's wrong with ice workers so ice for
those of you I don't know it stands for
Immigration and Customs Enforcement so
it's people that deal with immigrants so
what happened when they were serving um
they're like thanks or toggles our Bob
but I gotta take you in Buffalo New York
we didn't let food truck the taco truck
called Lloyd Loar and they're pretty
popular it seems they have a few trucks
even a restaurant so they post it on
their Twitter oh these are the owner
guys so then they posted on their
Twitter their regular schedule that they
always do
so then up here says like lunch 10:00
a.m. to 1:30 or 10:30 to 1:30 Department
of Homeland Security and then the
address right there huh that's ice
mm-hmm so then some people like looked
at they're under DHS then they realize
that this is an immigration detention
center something we're like the [ __ ] why
are you serving tacos to them so a lot
of people were upset and they said I'll
tell you where I'm never eating again
it's Lloyd's because they put out in
topology for serving Oh a homeland that
ones later sorry okay uh then they say
Danson you're only supposed to lick the
boot not make an entire meal out of it
what does that mean so they're saying
like they're like Lloyd is like kissing
ass pretty much they're taking oh so
they're winning I know
whoa you're not I I thought they were
catering to the guys in the Ice Center
like the cops will come and I'll be like
you guys want some food and then they
got they got all the tacos and then they
brought it inside no so they're kids so
Lloyd said like we're just parked there
like literally anyone can come we just
so happen to be parked in front of the
building yeah people people
exactly so a lot of people so then like
this here's another one that says how
about instead of providing for
government bootlick Oh bro you guys come
to the GM plant and give the workers on
strike some tacos just food for thought
no forehand out you want free food that
boys let's go out of business problems I
think pink it seems like it's oh you're
giving food I don't know I love when
people assume and they're wrong oh I
love it
Oh instead of making money why don't you
just come to my house and feed my whole
family you [ __ ] greedy ass it's like
that's literally what they're saying
bottom line here though why they got
upset is like oh you're gonna serve the
enemy now you're on their side that's
what happened why don't they see it as
you're taking the enemy's money [ __ ]
yeah yeah they don't so then here's
another one says that make sure that
people are tation squad gets their tacos
I guess pathetic choice to make a buck
so that's why the whole time I'm like
that's so nice they they're they're
catering to the ice prisoners business
man [ __ ] people come into your
business you don't know what the [ __ ]
what ended up happening almost are they
apologizing they they posted this on
Twitter they broken they broke into the
pressure
you didn't need to I would have been
like [ __ ] you my dick it was also very
like small it seems like compared to the
backlash that they got after this one
yesterday we made an honest mistake by
serving lunch at the Federal Detention
Facility and but Tuvia say that we're
sorry a few weeks ago we received a
request to serve at the facility and
processed it using our standard intake
procedure typically the process helps us
make business decisions we are proud of
unfortunately in this case it did the
opposite Lloyd has deep ties to the
immigrant and refugee communities in
Buffalo we work closely with Jericho
Road and the international institute of
buffalo as part of our hiring and
recruitment efforts and every year we
look forward to participating in their
buffalo without borders fundraiser there
is no excuse for what happened and we
have already begun to update our
internal put procedures to ensure future
truck stops and events aligned with our
company's values as part of our efforts
to make amends and learn from this
experience we are donating all of the
sales from yesterday's service to
justice for migrant families w
and why West New York we know that words
cannot change the past and a donation
doesn't make up for our lapse in
judgment only time in future actions can
show our commitment to being a more
thoughtful company today we begin that
journey
we're sorry Buffalo you deserve better
Lloyd so then the response to that
people said thanks for listening
apologizing making amends and resolving
to be better nice response eyes can go
to hell can go to hell and they can
brown bag if they want to eat another
one says feeding working Americans who
are just doing their jobs Americans who
specifically and with good intentions
requested your product and services due
to their admiration of said products and
services and you choose to dis and turn
your back on them I'm done with that toy
in what world does a company feel the
need to apologize for serving food to
federal law enforcement officers who
work in dangerous conditions pathetic
pandering the men and women who work to
enforce our immigration laws and protect
us protect us deserve better
so then that's how it can't be
reactionary dude you just got a do your
show today right [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz you're
gonna be wrong on that or what yeah this
is the final thing I'm going to show you
guys and this is a press conference that
the the Lloyd Trust don't they got so
much press yeah the time well okay so
it's actually they needed to do this
press conference because after that
previous apology they started getting
cancellations of like their bookings or
whatever for their food tricks so this
was causing some serious damage to their
business I'm gonna be another press
conference after this Prescott so then
now they're apologizing for initially
apologize and we reacted too quickly
eroticism we received early there's been
country so much stress
I want to clarify the fish around that
lunch stop our truck as we always do was
parked outside the facility and anyone
everyone in the neighborhood was welcome
to get the lunch there
we take responsibility for what
transpired last week but we want to
emphasize that we don't take sides
that's what people did in social and
traditional media in the last few days
it's a [ __ ] food truck I can't even
believe there's a press conference a
[ __ ]
I made some tacos for my homie once and
he said this is bomb yeah you should
sell it that's what I'm [ __ ] doing we
make tacos not policies we're not
getting involved so thank you know you
made a policy two days ago brother
apology [ __ ] it up Gina came out and
said I fired a PR guy yeah I fired our
PR guy and that's so sad man pretty much
the problem is the language in an
apology right it's not ever gonna speak
to the [ __ ] morons everything that
was said in that apology you have to
have some IQ to understand it
half of those [ __ ] words these morons
don't understand morons on both sides -
that's for sure exactly so you're you're
preaching to the choir using that kind
of terminology I would have just said
[ __ ] you I like making good food and I
like to feed people
I'm not I'm not allowed us ever speak
for my companies ever I serve everybody
period do you remember that story we did
where the waitress didn't want to serve
a transphobic table and that turned into
a huge thing to the point where now like
they shut the Facebook page down of that
bar like people are so so into the
politics right now it's anything but to
add more to the story they were saying
that you know how the company was
planning to donate to the local migrant
rights group it seems like that's kind
of fuzzy because both sides are claiming
that they haven't heard from one another
so even that right there it's like we
don't know and then so when the
entrepreneur refused to talk about
whether or not they would be macaque Oh
about it they don't want to talk about
it to me
that's our take on this [ __ ] cussed me
out rope no you're good you're good we
like yeah that's true you'd be the last
person a boy [ __ ] no one else can we
start a social media campaign to burn
geo down because it's worse than the
politics right now it's really bad I
don't like the pun stuff but me neither
[Applause]
I hate it I like I expected better from
you I really didn't I'm sorry I'm sorry
anyway so that's right cuz I can never
make them so when people make them like
that I like that yeah we were saying
they wanted they want to talk about it
no yeah so they said that they didn't
want to talk about whether or not
they're gonna be making lunch time stops
at the detention center in the future
what sucks is that Patrick these guys
are probably really [ __ ] stressed out
over this stupid [ __ ] it is so [ __ ]
stupid
let's do that [ __ ] press conference
they look depressed these points they're
a press conference too big exactly they
just want to make tacos they didn't get
they didn't [ __ ] get into this to be
politicians or role model ladies
gentlemen about 90 seconds to CEO of
Lloyd's tacos will be making a statement
these guys just wanna make tacos and
[ __ ] feed people that's it he's like
we make Gelineau chuck tacos we make
like Jabari talk about with the carne
asada version I guess yeah we call it
steak now he's like our salt and pepper
shakers they did not have very clear
usage there lot blocked very blocked it
would have been dealt with the whole
press conference was just them talking
about their menus hi I'd be the greatest
[ __ ] you we only bailing the new fish
taco today you got the new ice burritos
and the immigrant tacos we could be both
demographics I want to make a business
where right now it's like um I'm worried
about my friends and stuff and I don't
want you guys to get in trouble and all
that and then we still actually need the
money so we need to play the politics
game sometimes but when I'm super rich
to the point where you have that [ __ ]
you money I want to make businesses
specifically so I could talk a lot of
[ __ ] me too just I just want to be I
just want a taco truck and I want I want
I want that kind of publicity I want
people to talk [ __ ] about me say like oh
you're [ __ ]
feeding the enemy and
[ __ ] just so I could say [ __ ] you
they're delicious we should do a [ __ ]
China taco truck let's do it no you guys
love China all right we will never it's
we will never say [ __ ] you will net
right that's our taco truck I will never
say [ __ ] China because I will never also
say China's a corrupt communist
government [ __ ] Anna and I've never
said that that what China does which
people is terrible I've never said that
no one actually started a GoFundMe
campaign saying that they hope to raise
$2,500 to throw a free food truck rodeo
for the Detention Center guards oh my
god truck rodeo rodeos are fun that
could be quite as funny Steve I know do
it both sides are so [ __ ] China dumped
me I will never say [ __ ] China I will
never say China dumplings it's doesn't
roll as easily as the [ __ ] kind of
dumpling like that yeah we didn't say
that I mean we love money rice we love
[Laughter]
[Music]